we are getting new perspective on the
fight against coronavirus from the
generation that endured World War two
Hershel woody Williams is the last
surviving Marine to receive the Medal of
Honor in that conflict his trip this
ring to commemorate the 75th anniversary
of the Battle of Iwo Jima was canceled
but the 96 year old still has plenty of
advice about heroism service and
survival he spoke to our Jan Crawford
before we were encouraged to keep 6 feet
apart it's an iconic image of American
triumphs Marines raising the flag on Iwo
Jima sometimes when you see the flag you
think that's mission accomplished
no Hershel woody Williams 21 year old
marine from West Virginia had just
joined other Marines on the desolate
Japanese island some of them were
standing up firing their weapons end of
the air so I fired few hours in the air
myself but the worst was yet to come
the Japanese were underground they were
inside a reinforced concrete pillbox
we're out in the open you can't stand
back here and shoot all day you got to
move forward
I got flames on my back and of course
I'm carrying the gun in my right hand so
I'm actually crawling with one hand but
pushing mostly with my feet by the end
of that day Williams destroyed 7:00 at
Japanese bunkers allowing the Americans
to secure the airfield and eventually
the island an important toehold in the
Pacific this is you with the President
of the United States that is right yes
for his bravery
President Truman awarded Williams the
nation's highest military distinction
the Medal of Honor I don't think I do
anything special you didn't think you
did anything special but Williams wasn't
supposed to be there one of eleven
children his mother who needed his help
running their family farm refused to let
her son join the Marines at 18 he went
to enlist anyway when I handed him my
paper he just looked at me so I can't
test you can't take you yeah okay
I said when he said he was two inches
below the Marines 5 foot 8 cutoff as the
war went on they needed men and Williams
was in more than twice as many Marines
died on Iwo Jima than in all of World
War one among the many Americans killed
was Williams as best friend he sees his
medal as a symbol of others
sacrifice service service right we owe
something back Williams continues to
give back he's led the effort to build
memorials across the country for gold
star families who've lost sons and
daughters and our first scholarships to
the children of the Fallen and now his
country is giving back to him this
ship's namesake Williams was there
earlier this year when the Navy
commissioned this ship in his name
[Music]
Williams has traveled back to Iwo Jima
twice he hopes to make the more than
seven thousand mile journey again as he
turns 97 this fall on a trip led by the
national World War two museum that's the
Purple Heart
today s Americans face a different kind
of test
I asked Williams if he felt fear that
heroic day on Iwo Jima the fear takes
ahold and controls you you're done don't
you cannot possibly operate under fear
there's just no way and so you move
forward that's right even when the
bullets are flying you just have to move
forward right if you stop and
rationalize you wouldn't do it so I get
killed doing this crazy thing but you
don't think that way you got a job to do
you got accomplish a purpose purpose
yeah a purpose to move forward in a life
of service for all of us for CBS this
morning I'm Jan Crawford in onna West
Virginia
and of course Williams's right calmness
is strengthened we only have one option
that's to move forward and that includes
in this crisis